[Music]
you've seen the rock fight giant animals
escape the jungle and navigate a
crumbling city in a helicopter
now watch the rock fight giant animals
who've escaped the jungle while
navigating a crumbling city in a
helicopter before you see him get chased
by a helicopter into a crumbling
building dang got make so many movies
the honest trailer for his last one
comes out the same week as his new one
rampage based on the 80s arcade game
where you slap a button until your giant
eight turns into a tiny naked guy comes
a film that's only slightly less
ridiculous with action that feels like
it was drawn up by a little kid with a
box of crayons and dialogue that feels
like it was written by a little kid with
a box of crayons because all of our
research was on that space station meet
the Rob he's your everyday average
primatologist poacher Hunter x Special
Forces former helicopter pilot when his
bro rail adjourn sect it with outer
space growth hormone he'll have to use
every skill he learned communicating
with Vin Diesel on the set of fast eight
to take down a team of giant monsters
Billy could have done it all himself
because just like most of his other
films The Rock's character is literally
invulnerable I think you're missing all
the vital organs but Texas but Nomad
rampages alone you'll get help from
people like Naomi Harris is agent who
somehow convinced her this was a good
follow up to moonlight as she plays a
scientist who put every animals DNA into
a cocktail shaker just to see what would
happen we worked with bat DNA the growth
weight of a blue whale strength the
piranhas
eat all Africans painting us its DNA
makes it keep all the extreme
regeneration and Jeffrey Dean Morgan the
government agent who's more down south
and a jug of moonshine today huh 20
years in the cast of deliverance at a
Cracker Barrel oh well well look him
stealing the hospital world apart and
rednecky er than a biscuit with gravy
served on a confederate flag hubcap
thank you for getting this little cowboy
off their plane Oh Jeffrey you bless
your heart but you're from Seattle y'all
need to tone it down a little bit come
on let's give so if you're looking for a
pile of one-liners and CGI guerilla
fights held together by duct tape and a
likeable star you'll love The Rock's
latest city destroying adventure but if
you're looking for logic and depth from
the monster punching video game movie
then brother
you're about as dumb as a pair of
scissors yep
that's totally what I was gonna say
please don't hurt me starring he fought
a zoo George of the jungle
groggy she's ready to strike the ending
to the gray that we wanted Kentucky
Fried negan death stroked doctor science
and flail an actor woman Jurassic City
hey the rock really did teach they grill
everything he knew
my pet and his named Antonio Banderas
butter butter dirty line cutter that's
how eggs come from it last a girl
nothing's beyond her reach wonky wonky
doop Dube